my mother thought going to a white
school meant i would get a better
education
and i would be safer wrong
that's joey caruso a little thug with a
big chip on his shoulder
you know i managed to avoid him before i
wore these shoes
nice shoes bojangles ball jingles
that's not what your mother called me
when i was tap dancing in her drawers
last night
i know you think i'm crazy but if i let
him get away with that
he'd be doing it all year now i couldn't
beat him
but i thought maybe i could out-black
him what
did i stutter do you know who i am
you step on my shoe again i'm gonna tell
you who i am
i don't play that i'm from bed stop boy
i'll bring half of marcy up in here
i will beat your butt so bad you're
gonna need crutches in your sleep
hey this might work no one else i'm
gonna do
what's your name chris i'm dr raymond
your new principal
i get off my feet
that's funny that's not funny what's
your name son
caruso pick yourself up next time you
come to my school
see those shoes they say something
they say i'm a student i want to learn
i want more of that
and less of this
don't bump into me again
as a kid i wasn't superstitious but
everybody in my family was
if my mother spilled salt she would
always throw some over her shoulder oh
good luck
no
that's nonsense worth assault drew
wouldn't walk under a ladder
no matter what sonny help me i'm falling
i
can't get up if you want me to help you
you're gonna have to crawl from
underneath this ladder first
and tania believed that if she stepped
on a crack she'd break my mother's back
i wasn't superstitious but i did believe
in bad luck
mom i need some socks julia skip chris a
pair of your socks please
it'll be the only pair of socks you got
yeah
besides those are my lucky socks
i was wearing those socks tonight i met
your mother
girl he's cute but look at those socks
[Music]
i didn't think my father's lucky socks
would make a difference
hey little dude from across the street i
just hit the numbers wanna hold a doubt
yeah thanks that's all you lost
they not only made a difference they
made a dollar
you wanna just come stay at my house are
you serious
that'd be totally awesome yeah all i
have to do is ask my mom
boy are you crazy and why are you just
springing this up on me
so he can't come stay with us well maybe
it's just that i'm at work and i don't
have time to get ready for company
okay all right greg can stay but just
tell him don't expect anything special
i'm warning you man don't expect
anything special don't worry dude
i'm just happy to be here hello greg
for darts if this isn't special i'd hate
to see her overdo it
come eat help my mother is possessed by
a nice lady
class we have a new student with us say
hello to albert
hi albert chris you must be so happy you
must feel just like jackie robinson when
larry dovey arrived
more like robert pasch when dennis
johnson showed up who's larry dobby
was the second black man in baseball but
he was taller than jackie
and more strapping his
strong shoulders and nubian profile
this cleveland indians uniform
complemented by the rich caramel color
of his skin
and the way he swung his bat
forget jungle fever she's having a
jungle seizure
yes morello are you okay uh yes
anyway after years of being alone and
ostracized you now have a soul brother
somebody to talk jive with and to shoot
dice with
to talk about being raised by him a deer
with
just seeing the two of you together
would make your leaders like dr king
and uncle remus proud oh
happy day
she might have been crazy but she was
right i finally had somebody i could
really relate to
working with my father was mind-blowing
i couldn't believe how big it was
how loud it was how fast everything was
going
i felt like an amish kid in vegas
what's up george hey herb
who's this my son chris
who's her perk like hercules it's a
strong man
the only other names i knew my father
buy were the ones my mother called them
and they didn't have nothing to do with
being strong so
that hurt you funny like your old man
my father was funny oh he ain't that
funny
my father never cursed at home so
hearing him curse at the job made me
feel like i was in a secret club
the white house bring your mama back in
here
hey let's get to work i haven't heard
cursing like that since my father
stepped on my mother's bunion who needs
a test tube to make medicine when you've
got a tube sock
okay doctor thank you i'll mail you a
check
ah so what'd he say you were right okay
now is this ribbity or yours gonna work
no it'll work it's been passed down for
generations
my mother got it for my grandmother who
got it from her great-grandmother who
got it from a puerto rican lady
my father's home remedies were legendary
if you had a headache baking soda and a
pomegranate
if you are nauseous catfish and crepe
jelly
if you were blind a tin cup and a white
cane hey
he couldn't cure everything come on
[Music]
oh good lord man what's in this stuff
turpentine
don't be silly it's strawberry
turpentine
[Music]
that's working tanya went from healthy
kid to guinea pig
oh it stinks smells like feet be quiet
boy
i know it smells bad but if you drink it
you feel better
why don't you drink it well baby we only
had enough ingredients for your daddy to
make one dose and
you're the sickest it's yours you are
still sick aren't you
[Music]
yeah you'll feel better in no time
especially since there was nothing wrong
with her in the first place
[Music]
more bills junk mail
internal revenue service
we are pleased to inform you estimated
tax
refund oh
my god a tax refund check
is like a bonus for broke people a bonus
which my mother accepted with grace and
class
kiss my ass vida visa was actually the
name of the lady who collected bills for
mastercard
this is way too much that's way too much
our refund is
it's three times more than what we
expected that's how emcee and hammer got
in trouble
cool now we can finally buy stuff
without having to put it on lay away you
got that right hey
don't take your coats off why where are
we going
shopping we're going shopping
the problem with going to department
stores is every time a black person
enters they get followed
it didn't matter if you were a baby
wearing diapers she's on the move
or a senior citizen wearing diapers
she's on the roll
or even one of their own he's on the
move
what do you mean i'm on the move i work
here
sorry of course it happened
what's wrong with you man when he was
done getting answers out of me
my family started getting answers out of
a machine
i want to leave the message it has to be
a man's voice if i bought it i'll leave
it why can't i do it because everybody
hates you
everybody be quiet i'll leave the
message
hello thank you for calling
no one is available to take your call
right now
at the sound of the tone please leave
what's the difference some people are
toned down but nobody's beeped them
fine please
hello thank you for calling no one is
available to take your call right now
please leave a message at the sound of
the beep and we'll get back to you
as quickly as possible but what if we
don't want to get back to someone as
quickly as possible
it means you're a girl be quiet i'll do
it
i'll do it stop pushing that's not my
fault
last time hello
no one is available to take this call
right now please leave a message at the
sound of the beep
see is that good for everybody yeah
you sound like a white woman get out of
here before i smack the naps out your
hair
now she sounds like a black woman
you